a major escalation in Italy dozens of
Turkish troops dead the wounded taken
back to Turkey for treatment as a result
of the airstrikes 33 soldiers are
martyred none of our wounded soldiers
who are being treated in hospital are in
critical condition
Maher martyrs rest in peace I wish
speedy recovery for wounded soldiers and
I expressed my condolences to our nation
turkeys response was Swift Turkish
officials released footage showing the
retaliatory strikes saying they have
fired on all known Syrian government
targets near the Turkish border with
Greece refugees are waiting at the
border to cross into Europe Turkish
officials say they will open the border
to millions of Syrian refugees who want
to go to Europe reversing a pledge
turkey made to the European Union in
2016 the international community has
condemned the wars ongoing humanitarian
impact what is happening in Northwest
Syria they said is beyond imagination
it is not humanly tolerable the torn of
children so traumatized they no longer
speak turkey has given Syria and
end-of-the-month ultimatum to retreat
with Syria and its ally Russia refusing
to back down a humanitarian ceasefire
may prove elusive let's bring a DW
correspondent Yulia Hahn for more on the
story she's following it all from
Istanbul hi Yulia good to see you this
is a significant escalation can you
bring us up to date on the latest that
you're hearing from the Turkish side
well yes indeed this is a major
escalation in this direct conflict
between Turkish and russian-backed
Syrian forces there in Eid Lib we have
seen a number of clashes in recent
but that airstrike according to what we
understand has caused the largest death
toll for Turkey in a single day
since it first intervened in Syria four
years ago now Turkey has been hitting
Syrian regime positions in Eid l'p in
the past hours that's according to the
presidential palace in Ankara it comes
after a national security meeting was a
held in Ankara chaired by president
edwin himself so no signs offer backing
down here from Ankara and let me remind
you president Iran has also given
Damascus a deadline he wants the Syrian
regime forces to withdraw to previously
agreed ceasefire lines by the end of the
month which is essentially today or
tomorrow considering the situation on
the ground this is highly unlikely so we
might see more confrontation more
escalation in the days to come we know
that turkey is a member of NATO NATO
says it's holding an emergency session
today I mean what asks of what world you
think that this aspect of the story will
play well this has definitely become a
major issue for NATO the Alliance was
quick to condemn this deadly airstrike
and as you mentioned they are holding an
emergency meeting at Turkey's request
today Turkey one support from its
western allies it wants them to
understand that what's happening in
Syria right now is not just a Turkish
problem a Turkish issue and Turkish
officials will probably press for a
so-called no-fly zone in Syria to
protect the lives of hundreds of
thousands of people who have been
displaced there during the clashes now
interestingly the Turkish government so
far avoids blaming this airstrike
yesterday on Russia it blames solely the
Assad regime although it is widely known
and understood that the Syrian regime is
carrying out these attacks with crucial
support from Russia Russia controlled
the airspace over Syria
over it lips so this is essentially yes
a confrontation between Ankara and
Moscow with the potential of turning
into an open conflict between NATO and
Russia as well Julia you mentioned the
hundreds of thousands of people fleeing
the fighting they're heading towards the
Turkish border what will happen to them
by all accounts what's happening there
inside a lip is a humanitarian nightmare
we're getting reports of children
freezing to death because families have
to sleep outside in the open because
there is just not enough space and
nowhere for them to go so far Turkey has
not opened its borders to these refugees
currently stuck inside Italy but what's
interesting is that spokesperson offer
present aired one's ruling AKP said
yesterday the turkey was no longer able
to stop the four million refugees
currently residing inside Turkey from
trying to reach Europe and that's
basically reiterating a long-standing
threat by the president to open the
gates to Europe and we've seen images
here on Turkish television of of people
of refugees Syrians and other
nationalities gathering at Turkey's land
border with Greece and Bulgaria we've
heard reports of people leaving Istanbul
in buses and of course this is images
these are problems that that potentially
increase pressure on Europe as well to
act and to do something in this crisis
DW is Julia Hahn reporting from Istanbul
thank you